well welcome welcome to your mom's house
Christina the gypsies my life is hard
life is hard
what kind of makes you want to listen to
this that like for me even if who knows
what happens with the film but like that
works so shocking and crazy that I was
like whoa I can't believe I did that but
it feels really good too it gets things
out of you I don't know it's the best
acting for me is when I feel like
something from my life like really the
UM was undone and released its a Kirsten
Dunst and that's Kirsten Dunst
yeah oh wow she's a little vocal fry
they're a little kind of up there with
the the Lord of all improv whose
birthday it was birthday was just
yesterday I believe me Smurf day Steven
Seagal C gal turned 64 years old we
should point out that he has a couple
films that just hit Netflix oh I think a
good man and absolution are now now on
Netflix we should watch those we should
check those out I would love so we
should um but can't we sit through the
whole film that's the problem that is
the real challenge yeah yeah yeah here
she does do you think we could sit
through the whole film uh that was her
yeah gosh really uh at first I thought
it was a burn star ah ah
it's really something right she's mean
listen to she's doing good accurately uh
here's CL
and then yeah
she's a good actress she said she was
great in Fargo fucking amazing yeah
she's really talented I like her a lot
fart go fart go sorry yeah